everybody in here right now in a second
can think of something that they're not
good at that isn't noble that they're a
bad person in in a second that they know
they haven't addressed yet with
themselves that's intriguing that's the
beginning of the process
one thing I think I do well is I make
everybody feel safe and so that's really
important to me because when you make
people feel safe they start telling you
the truth I really really really believe
the thing that's holding people back is
the romantic version of who they think
they want to be or who they think they
are versus who they actually are just
cuz it's cool to be a start-up founder
now doesn't mean that's what you need to
become mark put on a hoodie and a movie
came out and you know Instagram made a
billion dollars after five hundred days
and everybody decided they were an
entrepreneur I fully fully one hundred
thousand percent with no hedge do not
believe that you can teach
entrepreneurship I'm a humongous
believer that ideas are [ __ ] and that
executions the game right we've all got
ideas everybody's got ideas doing
[ __ ] ideas we all have here we can
probably sit here for the next two hours
draw them all out record them and
predict the next 78 great startups over
the next nine years and we also have to
think about what are you good at
I built a very unsexy business in the
height of where I was and the game
because I was self-aware that that was
gonna be an engine for me over 10 20 30
years when it could have been a lot
sexier to raise fifty million dollars
and play with the 14 ideas I have but I
Know Who I am you can't just say any
people in here that I know intimately
say they're hustlers and then I watch
because I'm curious until they're just
not so you can't just say you want to
let go up there because if you're going
to go there you're gonna
look a lot of [ __ ] in the face that
you're not going to like if you do not
have self-awareness which is what I do
think I have and I think a lot of people
don't have it the only way you can gain
it is by getting other people to give
you the data points but most people will
tell you the truth so it's on you to
create an environment a very safe
environment for somebody to tell you the
truth this is the most important
question I will ever ask you in my life
you need to tell me the truth my
intuition is you're not going to want to
tell me the truth but you have to
understand it I'm ok with it
I'm in the right mind space for this I
need the truth and then you ask them
what do they think you're good at and
bad at of what they truly think you're
good and bad at and then gather that
data a lot of people don't want to
recognize what they're good at or don't
want to accept if you're bad at
something
and so I don't think people are honest
with themselves there's a lot of things
I wish I was but but I just don't lie to
myself and I think lying to yourself has
held back the far majority of this room
from bigger upside